se pactó un nuevo acuerdo económico un
nuevo acercamiento económico que
llamaron los dos mandatarios como la
declaración del Atlántico en este nuevo
pacto económico se quiere profundizar
aún más en los lazos de comercio en los
lazos para solventar el tema de o
mejorar las cadenas de suministro para
los dos países y también en temas de
tecnología en este tema de tecnología se
hizo el énfasis en el tema de la
Inteligencia artificial
dijo que esta nueva tecnología tiene que
hacer los países aún más seguros y no
más peligrosos en cuanto al manejo de
esta tecnología y el Primer Ministro
también mencionó que este el Reino Unido
va a ser sede de la primera Cumbre
internacional sobre Inteligencia
artificial en el tema comercial se les
preguntó porque aunque en el pasado se
había hablado de un tratado de libre
comercio entre los dos países todavía no
había sido y los dos mandatarios
precisamente respondieron que en esta
declaración del Atlántico se trataban de
limar algunas asperezas comerciales que
hubo en su momento sobre todo en el plan
de inflación que tiene Estados Unidos en
este momento el gobierno de Joe biden
que quiere subvencionar sus industrias y
hacerlas más poderosas en cuanto a el
comercio internacional y frente a otras
potencias como
el Reino Unido y la Unión Europea
Cristóbal se le ha preguntado también al
presidente Joe biden sobre la creciente
discriminación contra la comunidad lgbtq
que ha dicho el presidente al respecto
Sí es que este fin de semana es
el fin de semana de fiesta para la
comunidad lgtbq en Estados Unidos y el a
la casa blanca esta tarde precisamente
iba a ser un gran evento Yo bailen lo
alcanzó incluso titular como el evento
más grande que se ha hecho sobre este
tema en la casa blanca pero precisamente
dada las
circunstancias ambientales dada está
usted Hugo que está llegando desde
Canadá la casa blanca que iba a hacer
este evento en el patio de sur de la
Casa Blanca tuvo que posponer el evento
Así que frente a este tema también el
presidente Joe biden dijo que obviamente
está en contra de cualquier
discriminación que tiene un plan que va
a tratar de impulsar con el congreso
para limitar la discriminación a la
comunidad gay en Estados Unidos y además
una de las periodistas le preguntó sobre
si sabía del caso de una familia que
estaba pensando Incluso en dejar el país
precisamente por las amenazas que
estaban recibiendo sus hijos en el
colegio por ser de por ser parte de la
comunidad lgtbiq y él respondió a la
periodista que por favor le diera el
teléfono de esta familia que los iba a
contactar para pues invitarlos a que se
quedaran en el país y confiar en el
gobierno y trabajar juntos para la
protección de la comunidad